Nikki batiste is in Bristol Florida
about 50 miles inland from Port Saint
Joe she went to a shelter with 200 other
people getting away from the hurricane
that ripped out trees and snapped
telephone poles like twigs good morning
you can see just how powerful this storm
was this is the scene all across this
area downed trees down power lines were
also told some homes have been
demolished as this hurricane was coming
in we were rushed from our hotel and
told to take cover in a shelter which is
just down the street residents here are
not allowed to drive on these roads yet
so many of the more than 200 people in
our shelter this morning are waiting and
wondering if their homes are still
standing four-year-old Daniela alvera
began crying as she told us about the
terrifying moment a tree fell on her
family's mobile home they all escaped
and Daniela's mother Perla brought her
and her sister to a shelter you're here
your family's safe what do you stand to
lose back home
[Music]
material things that can be replaced the
old Vera's rode out the storm in the
same shelter as our CBS news crew get
out now or risk your life if you say we
were reporting from Florida's panhandle
Wednesday morning as hurricane Michael
closed in we just had to leave
Apalachicola because the storm is coming
in fast and furious the water which is
right here is rising quickly there's
debris along the roads as we're driving
after making the 80 mile drive to
Bristol we watched from these windows as
the storm pounded the shelter I could
sit in my front yard and see the bay so
it would be a direct hit Dan Haggerty
also left Apalachicola but many of his
friends chose to stay yeah anxious to
hear from them yeah I got scared because
if had surged is true I mean the whole
town's under water there are 41 shelters
across Florida housing about 8,000
people of the 375,000 people told to
evacuate the Red Cross says it's
probable 320 thousand never left
thank you very much Nikki